première réunion aujourd'hui à l'elysée
sous la présidence de françois
mitterrand du conseil pour les droits
des générations futures un conseil de
neuf membres
lancée à l'initiative du commandant
cousteau afin d'assurer le suivi du
sommet de la terre
réunis à rio il ya tout juste un an
daniela lumbroso
ils sont neuf neuf sages qui vont
essayer de ne pas le rester
chargés de jouer les trublions ils
devront tenter d'ajouter l'opinion et
les gouvernements en cas de menace
irréversibles sur l'environnement parmi
les personnalités nommées par le
président de la république on trouve le
philosophe michel serres le généticien
albert jacquard le biologiste jacques
testart et l'astrophysicien hubert
reeves leur mission trouver des
solutions aux problèmes posés par le
développement énergie surpopulation
aménagement du territoire
question auront-ils les moyens de se
faire entendre un comité consultatif n'a
pas de pouvoir exécutif ça c'était bien
mais il est certain que la notoriété des
membres de ce conseil et l
il sera difficile d'aller contre sens en
raison majeure
donc je pense qu'on a un certain poids
surtout étapes et du ministère de
l'environnement
face à ce conseil nommés par le
président de la république quelle sera
l'attitude du ministère de
l'environnement
non seulement j'approuve la création de
ce conseil qui est placée auprès du
président de la république mais qui va
travailler en liaison avec le ministère
de l'environnement
mais je crois que cette heure un élément
important pour la démocratie française
nous voulons pas marcher sur les
plates-bandes et d'un autre côté on peut
rendre service
enfin pour l'instant les plates bandes
sont intacts le conseil pourra être
saisi par le ministre les assemblées où
les associations première vraie réunion
de travail 20 juin si la terre continue
de tourner